hi this is fresh talker in this video
I'll explain why you can quickly square
a number ending in five the procedure is
that you take the digits that are not
five and you multiply that number by one
more than itself
you write that down and you put the
number 25 so let's go through the
algebra to see why this works a number
that ends in the digit five can be
written as X 5 and I put this number and
underline to emphasize that this is how
we write the numbers that we write the
number 15 that X is going to be 1 5 or
any number 95 X will be 9 whenever we
have a number X 5 what we really mean is
that X is in the tens place so we have
10 X plus 5 if we want to square the
number that's the same thing as squaring
10 X plus 5 when we square 10 X plus 5
we get 100 x squared plus 10x plus 25
the next step is to group some of the
factors so we factor out 10 X we have
10x times 10 X plus 1 plus 25 and now
this is pretty much the reason why this
trick works we started out with X 5
equaling 10 X plus 5 and now at the end
we have 10x times 10x plus 1 and this is
the part where we take the number x
times one more than itself so if we
rewrite the algebraic part in terms of
the way we normally write numbers we'll
end up with the number x times X plus 1
and 25 so if we have x equals 5 we end
up with 5 times 6 and then a 25 at the
end and that's why this
procedure works I hope you liked this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on Twitter at pressure Walker
or get my ebooks and Amazon